this is Tom Caswell I am here with Ben
janca hey there uh we are two of death
stranding's biggest fans on the Gamespot
team and we thought we'd break down the
death stranding 2 trailer with you
before we get started I do just want to
say Obviously we are breaking this
trailer down that's going to mean
talking about death stranding one
there's stuff in here that kind of
spoils a little bit of death stranding
one as well so if you haven't played
death stranding on or you know you don't
want to know any deaths surrounding One
spoilers this video isn't for you but if
you do and you want to learn everything
pretty much that there is to know about
death stranding 2's trailer we're here
to break it down so we're gonna Jump
Right In You Ready Ben absolutely all
right so the first thing we've got here
is this baby toy uh of dolphins there's
actually already a couple of Clues here
um obviously dolphins and like aquatic
animals they were the inspiration for a
lot of the the designs for the BTS The
Beached things the monsters in death
stranding one uh for people that don't
understand a beach thing is a soul that
has been disconnected from uh the body
in the real world in death stranding you
have to destroy the body by incinerating
it in order for the soul to move on uh
and so you have these battles with these
BTS and one of one of the designs is a
is a dolphin so I think that's where
this kind of like inspiration for this
to be a dolphin toy came in
um we also have a Bridges logo if you
see just the tail end there Bridges
being one of the uh kind of groups in
death stranding one on the toy on the
left if you can see that and then I
don't know if you remember this band but
um apparently at the end of death
stranding one I had to look this up you
get a sticker that says I heart BB do
you remember this at all yeah so I I
don't remember it was for beating it or
for like maxing out your relationship
link with them but you get like a whole
bunch of different patches actually to
put on your backpack gotcha and I think
they they added more when they put out
the definitive edition as well so you
could just kind of use that to fill in
spots on your backpack and stuff but I
remember the I Heart BB one specifically
yeah that seems to be what we have here
it's being used on this toy it's a
little torn as a sticker is want to to
get sometimes so yeah so we have the toy
now
you may say Tom you can't simply you
can't talk about a black screen but
what's very important about death
stranding trailers is they have these
flash cuts
to imply blinking like someone's
watching the trailer so this is other
than the stuff that we see in that first
bit there we this is also a clue where
they have these cuts to you know these
flash cuts to Black that this is a death
stranding trailer
so that the wonderful Kojima editing
yeah he loves he loves to he loves to
have these weird blinking edits uh you
want to talk about what we're seeing in
this scene here Ben uh so you've got one
of those cool little uh like you slot
the shapes in uh like a toy for a kid to
mess around with but the interesting
thing is here you you don't have all of
the usual shapes there's one that stands
up the circle right yeah the circle it
doesn't belong here uh so they're
they've got the crab shape which uh
you'd see a lot of crabs washed up on on
the beaches in the game uh which was
kind of an interesting thing and you've
also got like a the little transport
truck also back there which is kind of
cool that red block is the crab is like
the crab piece for him to or for her to
put uh into the toy as well that one in
front of the truck
yeah so the beaches in death stranding
one are basically kind of like limbo
they're like the Midway point for people
from between life and death uh so that
that's why there's a lot of like sea
imagery and uh and the crabs yeah would
appear on a lot of people's beaches kind
of creepily
um so yeah so we have again more hints
that this is this is death stranding and
we have a baby playing with the toys now
there's a lot of stuff in here I
initially thought this meant the baby
was two years old until I remembered
this is a ruler which means that uh uh a
height of two feet we also have the hand
prints from the baby which uh handprints
were signifying the a BT was near
because they'd be BT's usually invisible
so you would have to like go buy the
hand print and they'd have like this
there's this tar substance that comes
from the beach into the real world I
don't think that this is the task as a
substance I think that literally just
using ink to take the the baby's prints
um now I don't have a baby Bend are you
a father uh I do not have a baby as well
I I was just wondering like how old is a
baby that they could reach up to above
two feet
um but uh yeah they're they're over two
feet tall we're gonna see more of the
baby in a sec but again just more hints
that we uh that this is a death
stranding trailer and we do seem to have
a crypto buyout which are these like I
don't know what what what genus they are
but they're these little worm grub-like
things that they eat in the previous
game uh for sustenance essentially and
that seems to be like a plush toy of
that in the in the corner of the frame
there yeah
yeah
uh so we have again more blinking
now this is a very interesting
um
this I not mistaken this specific
imagery we have not seen before right
no it's it's the the interesting thing
about it is uh at least this is what I
picked up originally on seeing it it
looks like Amelie yes uh and I believe
which makes sense
yeah I didn't get a chance to actually
like cross-check this but the the order
of the knots on her kipu that she has I
think match up with the lines behind the
head
oh oh on the well we do see the kipu
yeah so Amelie is the is the sister well
it's confusing is the quote-unquote
sister of the main character Sam and and
DS1 she has this kipu this necklace and
you're right that does look like the
upside down the reverse height of that
kipu yeah I'm not I'd have to double
check but there's something in my brain
that's like that sticks out it looks
familiar yeah and we'll get we'll get to
the end of the trailer where we see it
so maybe we can cross-reference it there
but yeah so Amelie it seems to be this
whole sequence here seems to be this uh
well we got Sony interactive
entertainment so they're publishing it
again
um powered by decimal so there is this
cult that seems to be going on a
pilgrimage here uh so they seem to be
revering Amelie as a goddess Amelie in
death stranding one was an Extinction
entity basically the idea is that
throughout time there are these
Extinction entities
uh that come about uh that line up with
Extinction events on Earth and in the
universe I guess and it's meant to be
kind of like the universe is trying to
uh collapse in on itself and it you it
creates these Extinction entities which
Amelie was the sixth one that was meant
to bring about the last stranding
uh the last Extinction event to end uh
existence once and for all and um
that there were there were characters
that revered Amelie but they weren't
quite a cult it wasn't a religion they
were described as like a terrorist group
right you had Higgs at the head of it
but it seems like this is like that
taken to the next level so this is the
other interesting thing because I I
bumped into this just because I was I
was looking through the the Reddit for
like see what other people had also
stumbled yeah uh there's kind of uh an
interesting point here looking at all of
the design here it's really kind of art
deco with the figure which is the thing
that Bridges did a lot of their stuff
was yes Art Deco design and they've also
got the weird like butterfly things
uh on the on the sarcophagus going on
and maybe people are thinking that this
could be like Bridges after everything
that it happens and they'd kind of gone
over the edge and even Sam at one point
is like they're just a big cult
uh in the original game yeah there's
definitely elements of that at play and
there's obviously more stuff that we see
later in the trailer that hints at like
a Reformation of bridges as well but
yeah this definitely seems like a
combination of what we saw from the kind
of like the Amelie Fanatics in DS1 with
uh with that Bridges aesthetic now this
is clearly a casket and if you look at
the uh on the middle of the casket there
are these like open slits
um that you can kind of see through and
kind of hint at the character that I
think we're gonna see the end of the
trailer but they're clearly carrying
someone in this casket
um on this kind of pilgrimage
um now
I don't know what the what the heck I'm
looking at here uh there was nothing in
death stranding one that
I mean again you could look at this and
like oh the bits of the kipu kind of
like line up with these blocks but what
are your thoughts here then uh I'm
wondering if it's meant to be uh like
that's like a a a landmark or something
that we should sort of recognize but
it's broken up mm-hmm
uh there's a lot of thoughts on where
you this game is going to go like
physically uh because we've we've done
all this stuff in the US we went across
right the whole country so I'm wondering
if this is like
maybe some building or some sort of
structure like over in Europe or
something that might have kind of like a
thing it might be like a
uh
I I'm not quite sure but it definitely
sticks out the whole stand the imagery
everything is all all wild and unlike
everything that we saw in the first game
yeah there's nothing there's nothing
like this in DS1 we can also see strands
uh in like around the edges of this
Obelisk
um which signifies that basically and
there's again gonna be more stuff later
in the trailer that we see that
signifies that you know the end of DS1
the death stranding is meant to be over
Amelie is meant to have closed herself
off
closed her Beach off from the world
right so it's meant to be like the BTS
are gone the time full is gone and
everything but there's a lot in this
trailer that hints that basically all of
this is back and I think part of what
we're looking at is maybe this cult is
trying to create an artificial they're
trying to reopen the connection to the
beach Amelie's Beach specifically to try
and bring about the last training
because again in DS1 it wasn't like oh
you guys are safe Amelie was like a plan
initially was to bring about the
extinction quicker to kind of because
she felt like it was inevitable that it
was going to happen
um but in at the end she decides you
know looking at Sam that she's gonna buy
them time maybe they can figure out a
way so she's close the death stranding
is still like there it's just kind of
contained in her Beach and
um you know maybe this cult is like cool
like we can like maybe force and our way
out officially to uh to to re-kick the
last stranding backhand
um and maybe this gate has something to
do with it
um anyway let's continue
cool Kojima there we go so this is
Louise uh we can actually see it's a
little blurry on this on this trailer
but on Habib in the bottom right corner
there you can actually read her name
uh and this is a baby
yeah
um
from my understanding of babies
this is not she wouldn't be that much
older this is only a few months
maybe a year
after death stranding one based on this
baby
so very much a baby but it is grown a
little bit it's grown a little bit not
hair it's got hair and it's it's a bit
bigger I'm gonna say this is around the
one year mark
ish again neither of us have kids but
from everything I know about babies uh
yeah and this is yeah go ahead oh I was
gonna go into something that that's a
little bit ahead with the next character
we're gonna see so I could probably wait
to do that okay yeah yeah uh yeah I mean
you know so for people that uh are not
oh yeah you can see it a bit better
there Louise in the corner
um for people that don't there we go
perfect boom uh so for people you know
the ending of death surrounding one uh
Lou is the the name he uh Sam gives the
BB in his tank he takes it out of the
tank saves it that actually is what
causes Amelie to close her Beach uh
saves its life and basically starts to
seemingly is going to go raise it and
gives uh and Lou is for Louise who is
the baby that he lost uh in a void out
along with his own wife and it is being
held by the next character we see Leia
sidot a Ka the character of fragile and
there's a lot of interesting questions
here but you said you had something to
say about fragile so let's uh let's hear
it so I'm I'm I'm convinced that we're
looking at two different timelines in
this trailer sure and uh mostly because
of this because uh people who who played
the original game know that fragile
wears a jacket and closed the cover her
entire body uh she was forced out into
the the time fall to save a city from
blowing up to make up for a horrible
mistake she had a long time ago and
everything was basically forced aged
except for her face yeah
um and here you can see everything is
fine she looks great looking great yeah
uh so I'm wondering if this is pre that
I'm wondering if there are scenes later
on that are nightmares that she may be
having of when she couldn't save things
um the there's there's a lot to kind of
wonder about and unpack with that but
yeah I'm still trying to to figure out
I'm two different timelines maybe maybe
it's all the same thing maybe she got
healed maybe yeah and yeah you know I'm
gonna bring something up later when we
see another character about why I think
that this is
so you think that so you're saying that
you your hypothesis this is way later
I'm thinking this may be even earlier
which it makes
interesting uh like is it maybe a
different baby that is gone
Louise uh also be a dream like there's a
million things that can be but there are
there are wings on this baby uh I think
that is a part of the kala of the bib I
don't think that those are physical
although again stuff we'll see later in
this trailer
interesting it's like like a symbolism
like oh definitely something babies like
it like an angel they're not maybe
they're not they're not alive later on
or something now it's yeah now here's
the thing so the thing that makes me
think that this isn't a prequel or like
happened before deaths or anyone or
whatever is we do have Sam's dream
catcher uh yeah so Sam is in the picture
somehow she has the baby there's
obviously hints that they're raising the
baby together
um but this is Sam's dream catcher
um that he has given by Amelie when he
is a child
um so something just tells me that like
Sam is not around in this moment
um uh [ __ ] hits the fan that clearly in
a bunk of the sky is is a fake screen
Sky Amelie's looking around this is
Lou's BB tank that they're using as a
crypto buyout aquarium whether that is
meat do you think that's for utility uh
my my thing was is like they were just
like oh let's have a kooky aquarium and
our weird bunker house you know that I
don't know if there's necessarily like
anything that like oh we have it I don't
know if there's necessarily any story
uh to why it is an aquarium or they you
know utilizing it uh to keep crypto
biots but also I I feel silly for not
literally looking to the right there's
an ad for the pizza place right so the
pizza was one of the the pizza delivery
was one of the side quest chains in DS1
um there's also the ludens duck as well
on the right there and then
um which is uh a rubber duck version
that you can buy you can buy that from
kojima's like website uh of Kojima
Productions mascot ludens
and then there's also the thumbs up
sticker as well on a notebook which is a
a symbol that a lot of p a lot of
characters give in the first game
there's there's a part of me that hopes
that that's like a children's book about
like like like a like a nursery rhyme
about getting likes for like doing it
for people or something like it's a
bunch of it's a bunch of books to like
read to Louise or something yeah
that that he uses as that that Kojima
uses as like tutorials in the game yeah
you know at the beginning like it
explains the gameplay but it's through
these children's books I like that a lot
um so yeah so this flashing everything
is going to hell uh so something I want
to point out we do also see
um now here's the interesting thing
there is there is something to be said
about
um your timeline Theory because I think
we do actually get a fake out here
because you would say in this Frame I'm
using my mouse here to point you'd say
in this Frame
that that oh that's Sam's dream catcher
but it's not his dream catcher yeah it's
a different dream catcher and I think
that the fake out is maybe you'll write
maybe these are taking like this shot of
the Dreamcatcher is from something else
from something else because they're not
in the frame here we just have the room
there's like someone sitting in a chair
behind it is that someone sitting in a
chair is there something resting in a
chat because I don't see any like legs I
see the legs of the chair I don't see
like someone so maybe it's just holding
something maybe there's something on
there maybe it's an empty chair it's
very hard to tell because of the depth
of field but this dreamcatcher and that
dream catcher are not the same so they
are absolutely not and I didn't notice
that that's great yeah so I think I
think I mean look it wouldn't be a
Kojima thing if there wasn't gonna be
some fake out so I do think there is
something
to the case that we're not seeing things
quite in sequence in this trailer or
even remotely in the same time frame but
there is a dream catcher
there there's also if you see on the
left here there's moth MX which is
another symbol that we see later like in
a few
um shots
I Googled that that I couldn't find
anything on that
I don't know what that is seems to be
like the manufacturer of that's put this
bunker together again it could be
another one of these many companies it
seems that is formed after the end of
the death stranding
um any thoughts there moths also like
you talked about butterflies like that
imagery obviously like very important to
the the first game
yeah I think you might be on the right
track with it being like a manufacturer
uh at some point and that that might
just be like the the label for it yeah
we got another crypto bio toy uh down
here
um yeah I think we can move on to the
next shot obviously obviously not happy
with anything that's going on here
I don't think that there's really
anything obviously a hideo could you now
Ben I don't know if you know this hideo
Kojima the creator of death stranding
one this shot explains that he is also
making death trending too
which is interesting you know these are
the the heavy-hitting ones we're on top
of it
um okay cool yep more Panic shot from
this this is okay a couple of things
here first off
you couldn't convince me that this isn't
like a shot of Leia sedo this game these
cinematics look substantially improved
from DS1 which is already a great
looking game but like holy cow does this
look great the the lighting really just
yeah sells it completely too it's it's
really great the moistness of the skin
and the like you know what I mean like
she's really like sweating
um also the cuts that we get that are
meant to simulate blinks are no longer
simulating blinks they are legitimate
blinks like yeah that there's like an
actual closing of an eyelid uh so you
know we're getting more of that she's
looking around she's panicked panicked
more eyelids I thought this was
chirelium for a sec but this just seems
to be like overgrowth uh so maybe it's
like a forgotten bunker they found like
one that like wasn't utilized obviously
one of the plots of DS1 is they set they
initially had set up all these like
connective things and then the plan was
is that you know set them up across the
country and then reconnect them this is
Bridges right
um
but so maybe there's one that was like
off The Bean path that just like never
got reconnected to the network
I gotta play through DS1 again man great
game yeah
um someone is in here we don't really
get an opportunity to see who is
invading
uh the bunker but there is someone
invading
uh Leia sadow coming up top again behind
here on her right shoulder we see this
says moth MX but it's
it's mot hmx but again that seems to be
which makes me think that
this isn't a Bridges thing this this
structure it looks like it from the
outside maybe they've remodded it I
don't know
uh We've run outside here
uh there's this unicycle
which is very cool I love it a lot I
love it yeah it's very cool because it
gets a speed bike uh this whole bit is a
real bummer
yeah she gets shot in the arm
this is all pretty self-explanatory
there's nothing
who is this character with this gun
yeah I think flexibly you're supposed to
be like ah Higgs but like you can't yeah
he kicks Hicks for everything we know is
either dead or stuck on the beach yeah
from the end of DS1 we don't really know
what happens because Sam leaves Higgs
with fragile so we don't really see what
the the resolution of that is Higgs is
obviously like the first name that that
jumps out here but I don't think that's
who we're looking at yeah I don't think
it is either yeah
um okay now okay now we get into the I
mean not that nothing we talked about
wasn't interesting already but this is
the really interesting stuff so we've
got a shot now of the baby in the throat
which signified correct me if I'm wrong
but that was a rep a repatriation we
have repatriation stuff so it so certain
characters including Sam in the first
game could repatriate and every time
he'd repatriate he'd get the shot of the
baby in the throat
but this one's crying the tar substance
which we see in I think Higgs and Cliff
in the first game are the only two that
do that
um because of that connection to the
beach
uh so I don't really what are your
thoughts on the crying the tar crying
basically
that's also she's doing it she's doing
it here so she's repatriated which I
don't think in the first game she was a
repatriot
oh so maybe that's how she gets her
younger skin
maybe I I think they might I don't know
why I feel like they mentioned it but I
don't remember exactly when or where
uh no you know what she she isn't a
repatriot because
she has Dooms and I think that Sam is oh
yeah only I think Sam is the only person
to have Dooms and be a repatriot so I
don't think she was a repatriot in the
first game yeah she can she can see
these stuff right and that I think that
might be the extent of it but yeah she
could see her BTS and use her Beach to
travel those were like her two abilities
yeah
um Dooms being abilities that he Some
Humans got from like [ __ ] being [ __ ]
with the with the with the climate and
you know the world uh so we see Lou
crying then we have
um
fragile like pass out here I was gonna
say that that whole scene I think is
also removed from what we saw before I
agree I do not I mean clearly
everything's like on fire so something
has happened I think they may be
connected somewhat somehow but there's
something in the middle there it doesn't
go from what we saw before to this
there's yeah there's some other [ __ ] I
thought oh maybe a void out happened
because like everything's ruined but
this does you know they're not in a
crater the void out doesn't leave fire
you know it's kind of like a it's an
anti-matter explosion right so it's just
like a an abscess of anything so I I
think uh I don't know necessarily what
happened but again where those things do
not just happen one after the other the
first thing that popped into my head was
maybe maybe not even like an actual hap
maybe like a nightmare about the the
city that she ended up accidentally
nuking there's also that too right
because uh having nightmares was also
like oh you're having visions and stuff
like that in the first one so maybe like
there's some nightmare stuff going on
which would also play into your idea of
things kind of being on a different
timeline
um we get an interesting shot here the
broken uh BB tank slash crypto aquarium
uh where a loo BT seems to be falling in
so again in DS1 end of the game BTS do
not exist anymore because the beach is
closed so from what we're seeing here
you know and you know repatriation like
all these things should not necessarily
be possible
because the the death stranding is over
so the fact that Lou is coming back as a
BT
you know the the connection between
uh the death stranding that you know the
beaches and all that and the real world
is clearly like opening up or has opened
up again
um okay now now we have to pause on this
this this is when we start talking about
the the logos and stuff yeah so we do
see this is the first uh of the three
logos that Kojima put out that we see
but we get a little bit more we get
drawbridge
um which is a play on the word Bridge
obviously and we get the subtitle both
stick and rope to protect and connect
together for tomorrow
uh we'll see later in the trailer
there's some texts that come up that
says something like should we have
connected but what's interesting about
this is that you know both stick and
rope the idea that the they would these
were like the two first weapons or two
first items in the world the stick was
used for uh offensive purposes the Rope
uh to bring people together
and so what do you what are your
thoughts here there's a lot that I'm
thinking about I'm curious about what
you're thinking with this so I think
this is this is another uh like Bridges
uh uh set up in a similar way but the
fact that it's drawbridge makes me think
of what place has more drawbridges what
place has famous drawbridges
uh more thinking about like maybe this
being kind of like in like in a
different country yeah
um and maybe that there's another thing
coming up later on that makes me think
that we might be heading across some
oceans uh some other places sure but I
think this might be like a like a
Bridges but for another country
interesting my read on it was I was
thinking this is the net this is the
next incarnation of bridges now that
America is connected we're gonna go back
to our old colonialist ways and maybe
we're gonna start like trying to
reach out to other countries and that's
why it's both stick and rope because
their mission is no longer connecting
America their mission now is to spread
you know what I mean and maybe the whole
thing of like oh should we have
connected is that when we connect we are
creating uh scenarios in which we can
open ourselves up to be aggressors right
um you know bringing making you know
reforming America
you know maybe maybe has some some
implications some negative implications
for whatever's happened with the rest of
the world so yeah I'm also wondering
so that like a drawbridge effectively is
meant to be able to draw back to allow
something to go through it and I'm
wondering if there's any significance
there well I'm also thinking I'm also
thinking that this kind of looks like
a large support of yeah like the the
again right you're talking about a
drawbridge opening up uh in order to let
something through this is kind of this
might be like that like if if you think
about it maybe these two top bits were
connected right because they look like
they are chin so maybe it is like a
Gateway it is letting through the death
stranding
that that imagery playing into the logo
as well somehow like these floating uh
pillars set could have separated right
they could have formed that middle bit
and then split
to let something through to let these
people through to let the death shrining
through I don't know quite what but it
now that I'm spending time like kind of
like looking at this logo I'm like that
that looks very similar yeah um
but I like the thought obviously
imagery very important to kojima's games
and like he wouldn't have called it
drawbridge if there wasn't like a reason
so now
we get the reveal that Norman Reedus is
in this game and he has aged boy in what
is in what we've determined kind of up
until now only a few months so what are
your thoughts on an old Norman readers
uh I'm wondering there's a lot of things
in the scene that I I'm wondering about
uh old Norman Reedus I'm wondering if
this might be like another Kojima doing
rapid aging because of some sort of
weird thing happening again he might be
like afraid of Aging uh but I'm
wondering if the Detachment from the
beach has caused things to catch up to
Sam and that's why he's older
yeah I was seeing some theories online
that like maybe because he was a BB
himself maybe like you know a rapid
aging but I like the idea of it being
like the beach is now closed and like
now his yeah like now somehow uh he is
aging faster because of it I also had
the theory that he looks older has maybe
something to do with the fact that uh
fragile looks younger now maybe the way
you know they were like cool we saved
the world let's try and get you young
again and it required like maybe some of
that aging to be put onto Sam in some
way yeah not quite sure but I think you
know interconnected I think his aging
and the fact that Leia Sado is looking
normal or you know young again her body
at least
um so that that's the other thing though
she's covered back up in this which
makes me think that this is a separate
timeline right like a separate time
period so I am curious about uh her
being covered up I think it could just
be that she's wearing clothes you know
like she does throwing out the suit but
there is that possibility that yes this
is her with her older body again uh so
we see something here that is very
reminiscent to a metal here when I first
watched this trailer I was like this is
a goddamn Metal Gear uh I I should say I
I had so many people hitting me up about
this specifically and uh it's it's it's
not even just like reminiscent of a
metal gear it's the silhouette it's the
top just like literally without the legs
it's metal gear Rex's head like yeah
really the like Cannon and everything
okay cool instead of it being a cannon
it's actually a crane
I've added uh in post I'm gonna be
adding uh yeah
like a little bit further ahead like see
where you get like the kind of three
quarters yeah yeah yeah
because and it looks like a mod like at
first you think it's a big gun but it is
um it is a crane it's a crane instead
instead of the the
maglev launcher the I forget what it's
called exactly it's it's it's magnetic
and it shoots nukes and it's dangerous
uh but it this looks like metal gear X's
head that's awesome
um so we do have the drawbridge's logo
here on the side we also have the squid
logo which is our first time seeing that
from the trio of logos that Kojima
posted on Twitter uh with the words D I
think it says dhv Magellan uh try to
Google that uh in relation to death
stranding couldn't find anything but
Ferdinand Magellan and I'm pulling this
from Wikipedia uh is an Explorer best
known for having planned and led the
1519 Spanish expedition to the East
Indies across the Pacific Ocean to open
a maritime trade route during which time
he discovered the inter-oceanic passage
bearing there after his name and
achieved the first European navigation
from the Atlantic Asia the the Strait of
Magellan uh is this like basically
straight that cuts through South America
um so that again plays into the idea of
this not taking place in America us
going beyond the boundaries of America
uh any thoughts on that I was just
saying I'm thinking because when the
scene starts up you actually hear
seagulls which makes me think we're on
the coast um uh and I'm thinking we
might still be on the the west coast and
we're finding a means to go across the
ocean to go and see something in a
different country I think this is like
the big embarking moment in the story
when we actually head off and it's
through the help of this
this ship that fragile has that we're
able to do it gotcha very cool uh we do
see someone piloting if you can see in
the uh cockpit that is someone seemingly
sitting in a seat there
um we have the words I think it says
born of Roma lawn Roma uh in the top
left
um maybe that's the name of this machine
it says xcv 5800 is what I'm reading
again I try to look up this there seemed
to be nothing on it already we've got
8308 is another number down in the
corner here
um we have this shot of uh Leia Sido
crying now she could just be crying
because she's sad because something
happened to Louise if this is taking
place after what we saw in the beginning
of the trailer but crying signified
chiralium and uh chiral Mata being
present
um and like Time full about to happen
and all that stuff in the first game it
was like an allergic reaction so again
hinting at the idea that uh the bridge
though the the the the the gate the
Gateway between the afterlife and the
real world is
um opening up again and yeah fragile
here says meet my crew Sam or something
to that effect yeah so she knows these
people
but it doesn't seem to be the company
fragile that she like inherited from her
father and uh ran like this is a new
thing right like so maybe this is like
what what are your thoughts on that
I I think it it's it's got to be
something that she just comes upon later
on because I I know that there's a whole
thing with like
Fragile the the company got
like the the whole reputation of it was
thrown off when they figured out the
terrorists were working in there walking
through fragile right the company not
the person yeah yeah but also through
the person a little bit uh so maybe this
is like a new
a new thing to kind of like detach from
that and make her own thing uh yeah
wasn't that something like correct me if
I'm wrong but in the first game I
remember I think reading or hearing in
one of the things like Fragile the
company kind of like connecting with
Bridges like didn't that happen at the
end like there was the merger yeah I
think of that effect so maybe maybe draw
Bridges is the connection of the two
like it was meant to be like the United
States Postal Service and FedEx and now
the parts of a bridge
oh the drawbridge it's two halves of a
bridge and therefore to make we've drawn
it together they've drawn the bridge oh
my god
um okay we get a shot of the underbelly
here this is awesome like I'm just so
stoked to
see more of this we get number 8303
that's the same number on the front so
you know make that what you will there's
8 303 kind of like all over the chassis
of this thing uh old Sam
he's having to cry too so unless they're
being sad together they're having an
allergic reaction to some death
stranding stuff
um now here's the thing we see obviously
in the previous shot of Leia sadows
character fragile she had straps on her
in the front there seems to be the top
of what looks like a BB tank strapped to
her so I wanna I wanna throw you this
Theory and I want to see what your
thoughts are and what you think about
this yeah I think
someone is after Lou
right
um I don't know if it's necessarily
Higgs or what have you in his cult it
doesn't seem like that I think that
might be a fake out I don't think that
that's who's after him but I think that
Lou dies
uh the but they have its body
and she is Lou is resurrected as a BT
that now lives in the pod
and they are trying to because a BT is a
soul that is trying to find its body and
reconnect with its body so they're
thinking if we can get the body back
and connect the BT with it we can bring
Lou Back
and which is why they may be crying they
might be like oh a baby's gone
you know it also isn't the first time
someone had kept a BTE baby around
because they wanted the homama fix it
right uh yes so that that could be a a
big thing I also talk about the fact
that the thing that's holding that uh
the BT container looks like hands and it
makes me uncomfortable
I'm sure I'm sure that there's some
imagery like that you can you can see it
a bit better in the other shots but it's
it's kind of a weird uh thing that I
just noticed uh yeah in the front yeah
it looks like hands reaching it's yeah
down yeah um but it it I I like that
idea of of BB maybe being a BT because
it's being very intentionally kept out
of the shot
yes it's very intentional that we're not
seeing what that is it also could be
like the head of a baby as well like it
could be Lou human in her head
um it's it's so hard to see because you
just see you just see the top and you in
the depth of field and all that but I
think that that's a good story and I
think that it could be like maybe
they've been hiding and now they have to
go now they have to venture out because
it is to save Lou like that to me kind
of like makes that's a good like
emotional story that's a good place to
go that's just a theory that I have for
him uh I'm also I'm thinking about the
the crying allergic reaction to stuff
and I don't remember if the the tar
specifically set it off because the
thing is coming out of the tar
um and I'm wondering because the the tar
is used to transport things from the
beach right so that's the other thing is
this machine is coming out of the tar so
I'm wondering if that's like like a fast
travel thing or something and they're
just using that ship to go through it
and
or are they able to go back to a beach
or I mean they must be right because
like taw's presence means that there is
a beach connected I don't know if it
necessarily means like Amelie's Beach is
open they may be crying because of that
maybe the
I think there is chiralium in the tar I
always kind of like this is where like
my everything gets hazy for me on like
yeah what is causing the crying
um but yeah so I but I do think that
that is what is happening like they have
used uh the beach in some way to to
transport this ship to them
um
then we get the list of the cast members
no one readers are training they said
Ellie Fanning and Shirley katsuna uh who
were teased uh they were the first to
teased uh to be in this game we didn't
know it was deathtronic at the time we
just knew it was the next project from
hideo Kojima and then Troy Baker is
returning who is singing The BB's theme
um in the background of the trailer
itself which I also I don't know if it's
going to be significant at all and it's
just a really quick thing that I noticed
uh intentionally leaves the first two
lines out of it when it starts up uh I
don't know what it's not significant or
anything yeah
[Music]
uh only gonna be on PS5 no PS4 uh so you
know hopefully you can get a PS5 in time
before this game to come out using the
Decima engine which is uh right the
Horizon forbidden West engine
there's so much here that like okay so
like we're gonna spend another 40
minutes talking about just this there's
so much here so these are
do I wanna ahead let's just continue
Okay so
okay
you know what you stop Ben okay so first
first thing I'm going to point out
because it doesn't have any sort of big
significances when uh when whoever this
is hits the the guitar uh the people in
the background have the little
exclamation marks on their face and I
like that a lot oh I did not even notice
that that's awesome so I'm really
excited whenever I get to see the
exclamation mark pop up that's just a
quick little thing I have it I have an
exclamation mark t-shirt I should have
won oh I guess people on I was seeing a
video they're just hearing us but yeah
so it's it's it's it's all good but yeah
uh so who we're looking at uh
instinctively one might want to be like
ah it's Gotta Be Troy Baker's character
because they're singing
I I don't know if it is it might be part
of Troy Baker it might not be uh I it's
got Amelie's hair it's got her kipu uh
it's got there's stuff on the face her
face is uh like more of uh
Amelie's face like the structure of it
like that's not higgs's like facial
structure it has eyelashes like feminine
eyelashes on it as well if you zoom in
like there's like that silver around the
eyes
um you know it just yeah and then yeah
on the guitar strap you do have uh
you've got the butterfly things you've
got a symbol that looks like the
uh like Amelie statue that they were
carrying around
um and you have uh I mean he's got this
like exposed stomach area looks kind of
like his that they I'm gonna say they
because it's an androgynous character
now there they have like this BB
container Tech stomach
so so maybe let them use their Aura deck
without a baby
oh that's right and all you need to
debate a BB to to use that
uh and I know uh there's another thing I
was reading about how uh Higgs was kind
of really into like Egyptian type of
like uh ideas and stuff and there's
something about like organs in a jar and
having all of your organs being kept in
a place like that out where you can see
it that kind of sort of mentally makes
my brain do a thing but uh interesting
I'm wondering if this is some sort of
combination of
um Amelie and I think that's what it's
going to be yeah I think what it's going
to be is that Higgs was left on the
beach and
this cult somehow brought him back but
it's not just him it's Amelie and now so
like it's it it I mean that would be the
ultimate Higgs an anomaly cross breed
would be the ultimate villain because
it's it's Higgs with his like nihilistic
like I'm bring about the last string
like I want this to happen with Amelie's
like ability to do that like they would
again talking about two halves making a
hole like all this stuff like Higgs had
the will and Amelie had the power to
make the last stranding happen but
they couldn't because they were they
were ultimately at odds like that that
their choices were at odds and so like
the idea again of a drawbridge of these
two halves kind of connecting like if
this is some kind of like Higgs uh
Amelie hybrid you know what's stopping
him from bringing about the last
stranding if he now has the the keys to
the kingdom so to speak yeah um he has
an uh an ordered Audra deck I don't know
how you pronounce that
um which again you need those to detect
BTS Like so BTS are back like why do you
even have this like he didn't even need
one the first one why did he even have
one in the first one right because he
could see BTS
yeah do you I don't know it's it's a
thing and I'm also wondering uh in
whatever we're looking at I'm guessing
uh some big part of was in that
sarcophagus
and this is post getting that delivered
yes I mean I I think he this this entity
this homily
this homily
um I think they wait he was in that
like I think he was in that sarcophagus
whether it's pots of him I don't know uh
I I think he looks it looks cool though
like I think like this is such a cool
design and like absolutely speaks to I
think some old school like metal gear
solid uh villains and stuff like that
like we're getting a lot more of that
now which is exciting
um should we have connected so that's
that's gonna be the theme you know hideo
Kojima did say after talking you know
after showing this trailer off at the
game awards he basically said
uh I wrote the the second game the
pandemic happened I scrapped it and I
completely rewrote it so that's
something that you know to keep in mind
as well of like this intention of like
should we have connected like
um are we really better off for having
done this uh I'm sure that you know
that's going to be a main theme of of
the game
um also something real quick before we
get out of here uh something that was
said a line of dialogue that was said by
a character that I haven't I could not
recognize the voice of
said something along the lines of it
wasn't the united united cities of
America that did this it was aipac which
is the third logo that we don't see in
this trailer but again Kojima teased it
and it stands for automated Public
Assistance company uh you'll see the
logo on the screen right now uh it has
like this very East India Trading
Company look it's like this compass look
Navigator's company again like another
maritime
hint that we're going to be Crossing you
know water going somewhere else that
isn't America and you know the first
game
you know that was America right like
it's meant to be you are going from the
east coast to the West Coast so it makes
sense that the next game takes would
take place in in a new location or
extend where we could travel to
um and I think oh I forgot about this uh
so we get a bit of dialogue here of
um
Samsung Lou like and it's and it's this
octopus
that's in the in the BB tank I'm hoping
this is one of those weird little like
nightmare things that happened while you
were in your room because I don't I
don't want I want Ludo to be turned
octopus octopus yeah uh but yeah that's
that's uh
it's a bit a bit spooky yeah I wonder if
it's like the the BT is kind of like in
flux like it's something's happening on
the beach that is you know causing it to
influx but again I remember I remember
there was a ton of stuff that was teased
when they were showing off trailers for
death surrounding one that was like what
am I looking at and some of it was in
game but some of it yeah was like a
nightmare that he was experiencing
obviously like him traveling to like you
know uh all the stuff with cliff and all
that turned out to like be not really
happening
um so maybe that is what is happening
here uh as well yeah I I have no clue
octopus you know we've got squids
octopuses we've got the Magellan logo
that looks to be like a an octopus or
whatever or a squid so I don't know that
that one is like totally up in the air
um so there we go that is the that is a
full breakdown of the death surrounding
2 trailer uh any uh closing remarks here
uh Ben
uh
not other than I can't wait to see more
of this
looking at every single trailer as close
as I can and please if anyone else uh
notices anything that we skipped or
didn't see or anything yeah let us know
in the comments for sure I'll be reading
all of them because I'm very excited to
just gather information and go crazy
about a new Kojima game yeah 100 yes
please do let us know in the comments if
there's anything that you think we
missed your thoughts on our takes on
what we saw here in the trailer please
also like this video And subscribe to
Gamespot because this is the tip of the
iceberg for our coverage on death
stranding too and until next time
everyone